hi friends it's sara bareilles here with
the rest of my girls
five eva and we are gonna rate some 90s
fashion trends
all that means that we can bring back
the trend
but as if means that it's gotta go it's
not coming back
all right let's do it
oh tiny sunglasses all that or as if
what you know what let me just say can i
just say this
you have the face that can carry a small
a tiny sunglass
oh do you know what you have like a per
you can do it you're cool enough your
face is perfect
yeah good for attitude but not for my
prescription because
i always wear glasses and i get panicky
with tiny lenses like that
it's three as if's and one all that
so renee i'm so sorry well
more from me are those low rise
jeans i'm as iffing the low-rise jeans
because i have never since i was born
uh could wear rise jeans it is uh
abomination can i tell you i didn't like
that
then i don't like it now no one needs to
see my butt crack
no i want my jeans to hit my collarbone
do you see how high my jeans are right
now those are cute
yeah so guys we're as if on this all the
way not happening
guys platform sandals happening it's
big all that for me they're good for a
jog i like
like a like a slightly an elevated jog i
love a platform that's
solid but gives you a a little a little
bounce
you know what's crazy it's like this the
platform
is like shows me my evolution because i
hated them in the 90s i didn't want to
be too tall
what crazy i mean i'm embarrassed to say
and now
i love them and it has nothing to do
with my height i
love them we have poor all that we did
it all that
bring them back yes guys bring
back velour oh my god in fact they're
back
i'm about to go put mine on right now i
love
a cute matching track suit
i love it i do not ladies i am the
outlier here
sarah i know it's like wearing the rug
it's like wearing a gentle rug and i
just i've never been into them and maybe
it's because i associated them with just
like some
[ __ ] from high school
and here we are right here all three of
us
i love soft fabrics give them to me i
want to be
you know you this is in your merch right
now busy it is basically
you guys three to one sorry sarah we're
bringing them back
velour tracksuit you can have them
oh my god bedazzled jeans oh my god
i mean you guys no i'm gonna put
both because it really depends wait
i'm shocked sarah can i just tell you
okay here's what's going on for me
they gave me bedazzled jeans to wear for
the show
and i put them on and i don't know if i
was just overwhelmed
with nostalgia but boy did i love
the way my ass looked in those [ __ ]
jeans
let me tell you something my booty never
needed
any more bling than it already had then
a show don't need it now sarah you can
keep the jeans from the show
the rest of us don't think i didn't ask
okay
they're out of here oh chokers
guys i think jokers are kind of wait i'm
wearing one right now
i love chokers i'm gonna have one uh
disclaimer here i have
a terrible gag reflex so
i love turtlenecks and i love chokers
but it has to be a certain
kind because i will be like having
dinner and talking to people and all of
a sudden just start gagging because i
can't stand
anything how are we the same person
paula
it is so weird we are like genetically
must be like
one slight sliver away from one another
because i have the same exact thing
i only liked it for the bedazzle then
now
i can just go right right in between the
line there and the line there on my neck
you can just slip right into that groove
right there
i see the purpose for the choker and the
platform
okay guys well it's unanimous we're
bringing back chokers we've already
brought them back
a bucket hats guys i know because i have
a teen in the house
bucket hats have been back i think
they're cute on some people i'm as
iffing because i have
the biggest head i've had people tell me
in hair and makeup departments that i
have
the biggest head they've ever measured
like known to man
and so hats are usually something i can
only look at through
through a store window like a child
looking at toys
i think they've told you all you need to
know about this item
in the name it's a bucket hat
it's a bucket hat it's a bucket
i think they're cute i think they're so
cute i think
you know it's doing more than just
keeping you warm if you know what i mean
you know because it's you know sometimes
your hair it just needs to just be
poking out down here but you don't need
to know what's going on up here
correct all right well this is a tie
a real tie renee and i will be
wearing our bucket hats on our bucket
heads
oh you guys i use these butterfly i use
butterfly clips all the time
i use them all the time yeah i only use
them for as styling accessories
like when i'm styling my hair to hold
something unanimous we're bringing them
back
they never laugh love love them
okay that's what i've been waiting for
you know why
i need two all that me too
you know what i'm saying all that square
i'm joining you
and let me tell you something i'm glad
this came back
because i never stopped wearing them
wait can we talk about what recently did
start bringing them back
what happened common sense i
just want to say i feel like we have
black women to thank for that
i do okay renee i mean
because black women black women have
been very concerned about breaking
off their hair there you go and we put
our hair up in ponytails when we go to
sleep our little balls on the top of our
head before we go to sleep
black women have always been about the
hair care
right and uh and a scrunch a scrunch
you know it's just loving your hair it's
fine all right we're bringing back
scrunchies
throw it back to the 90s and soak in all
the nostalgia
stream girls five ever only on peacock
you